[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez bien oui non parce que moi je
suis très très en colère
par contre vous pas maintenant en
particulier mais en général je suis
plutôt quelqu'un de mécontents je suis
même une grosse râleuse en faites pas
vous c'est sûr y'a rien qui vous gonfle
rien qui vous les boules
rien qui vous mettre sur les nerfs n'ont
vraiment rien qui vous emmerde
bon je m'arrêtais là parce qu'il paraît
qu'en 2019 il faut être content donner
le change à voir un sourire ultra brite
on vous l'a sans doute déjà dit non que
ce soit l'ami de votre tante qui est
coach en développement personnel ou le
manager du bonheur récemment débarqué
dans votre boîte pour organiser des
apéros et des jeux que ce soit le petit
livre de citations zen qui vous nargue
depuis votre table de chevet vous savez
vous ne l'avez jamais ouvert où la barre
de céréales aux oméga-3 sans gluten sans
lactose sans sucre et sans rien qui gîte
en miettes au fond de votre sac et de
votre mauvaise conscience aussi malgré
les meilleures intentions du monde
évidente
tout cela participe d'une même chose
c'est la tyrannie d'un bonheur bien
lisse d'une existence sagement
consommatrices orchestrée par de
multiples experts qui vous pousse à être
performant et même plus que cela à être
entrepreneur de vous-même réussir ou
n'être rien disent certains cela
consiste en outre à gommer vos
faiblesses et donc certaines de vos
émotions
concrètement on le voit très bien avec
instagram par exemple pour ne citer
qu'un seul réseau social le plus
narcissique de tous sans doute qu'ils
nous invitent qui a montré le meilleur
de vous même et de ce qui vous entoure
ces pratiques n'est ce pas
car il n'y aurait ainsi plus aucune
raison de s'indigner alors je suis
d'accord avec le fait qu'il vaut mieux
viser le bonheur que l' inverse dans la
vie cela va de soi à quoi bon
franchement sinon quand on connaît
l'issue de l'existence mais le bonheur
la joie ne sont pas des biens
consommables et il ne consiste pas à
refouler vos émotions négatives
alice est votre insatisfaction à vous
convaincre
invariablement que tout va bien moi
c'est simple sans ma colère je ne
pourrais pas exercer mon métier je ne
parle pas d'être colérique et ne violent
non bien au contraire je parle d'
écouter sa colère de lui donner une
place ce qui permet ensuite d'empêcher
la violence
spinoza au xviie siècle une conception
assez nouvelle des affects en
philosophie occidentale du moins il ne
devrait pas être séparé de la raison
dans une perspective dualiste il ne
serait pas moins légitime qu'elle
spinoza en outre remarquer que plus une
émotion et vivent plus le désir qui en
résulte est grand nos affects influence
notre puissance d'agissements plus on
est en colère
plus on est déterminé à agir d'après
annonay ce philosophe spinoziste
écologistes norvégien il existe en outre
deux types d'affect les négatifs tels
que la colère et les positifs tels que
la joie mais attention ne s'agit pas de
distinguer le bien du mal et cette
division n'est pas immuable les affects
négatifs peuvent devenir positif
lorsqu'on mûri dans notre vie affective
ou dans notre réflexion les affects
négatifs peuvent donc aussi poussé à
réfléchir prendre une décision pour agir
même et surtout de façon non violente
le sentiment de colère qu'il soit issu
d'un choc d'une prise de conscience
brutale ou qu'il résulte d'une longue
réflexion peut être positif
regardez les militants écologistes non
violent par exemple où les lycéens
convoi faire grève en ce moment ils
manifestent font un sit-in s'installe
devant une parcelle de nature sauvage
pour empêcher son saccage par un projet
industriel
c'est une action concrète qui a déjà un
premier impact réel rendre le problème
visible alerter l'opinion publique
pourtant cette action est bel et bien
partie d'une colère immense celle que
l'on ressent en voyant de puissants
lobbys continuer à anéantir la bio
diversité et cela en toute impunité la
colère quand elle n'est pas refoulé mais
qu'elle ait mûri réfléchi transformer ou
sublimer comme dirait freud peut-être
une incroyable source d'énergie positive
de changement ou d'épanouissement
alors bien sûr faut apprendre à la gérer
un cette colère qu'elle ne se transforme
pas en à un chaos pulsionnel en une
violence aveugle mal digéré est mal
dirigé mais pour cela il est
indispensable de lui donner une place ou
de se battre pour la conquérir le cas
échéant et la garder l'écriture est une
possibilité parmi d'autres quand on a la
chance de pouvoir saisir sa plume
en ce qui me concerne même si je n'écris
pas tous les jours je pense tous les
jours aux sujets que je traite dans mes
livres
car l'écriture c'est la vie je ne
parviens pas à distinguer les deux et
j'y mets donc tout mais affecte y
compris et surtout mais grande colère
quand on demande sur quoi j'ai écrit et
que je réponds l'écologie le féminisme
le monde du travail
on s'étonne ah mais ça part dans tous
les sens ton truc là au début en effet
j'ai pensé que je me disperser au lieu
de me spécialiser
mais il ya un dénominateur commun à tous
ces sujets il est éminemment politique
c'est l'indignation directement issue de
la colère
mon livre sur les start-up visait à
déconstruire cette culture hélas trop
souvent malhonnêtes et injustes
elle célèbre l'entreprise du futur
prétendument libérés tandis que les
petites mains du numérique travaillent
dans des conditions dignes du 19e siècle
elle se vante de sauver le monde
tandis que certains dirigeants de la
silicon valley dépense des milliards
pour se construire des petits bunkers
bien isolé bien confortable pour
échapper deviner à quoi à l'apocalypse
lorsque j'ai écrit sur l'allemagne
c'était pour montrer l'autre face du
prétendu moteur économique de l'europe
vous savez avec son taux de chômage
officiel si faible et si enviable en
réalité un enfant sur cinq est vite en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
le nombre de travailleurs pauvres ne
fait qu'augmenter la contribution des
femmes revenus du foyer est la plus
faible de toute l'europe et la moitié
des mères ne travaillent qu'à temps
partiel pendant ce temps là tranquille
des start up se sont massivement
implanté à berlin profitant allègrement
de l'absence de salaire minimum légal
dans le pays
des années durant pendant mes études de
philosophie
j'ai travaillé sur sartre a vendu
consacrer une bande dessinée sartre
l'intellectuel existentialiste et
engagés dont je me suis de plus éloignés
mais qui m'a marqué
quand mes textes prennent forme il y est
souvent question de mécanismes de
domination de rapports de force qui
m'ont touché un moment ou un autre plus
ou moins personnellement parce que je
m'efforce d'écouter ma colère je
pourrais m'acheter un punching ball vous
dirait un ce serait plus rapide et en
plus je n'en reviendraient personne mais
je préfère boxer avec les mots en plus
sartre et naissent les deux philosophes
que j'ai cités étaient tous deux boxeurs
pour de vrai
alors c'est bien beau tout ça la boxe et
la colère mais c'est vrai l'année
dernière j'ai connu de grands moments de
découragement faut dire que l'actualité
n'est pas franchement réjouissante
j'en suis venu à me dire que même écrire
des livres étaient vains quand on
s'inquiète de la fin du monde de la fin
du mois peu importe comment vous écrivez
moi d'ailleurs
en plus j'ai eu 30 ans et 30 ans c'est
l'heure du premier bilan
ne souriez pas un je parle du premier
bilan carbone ce n'est pas bien glorieux
malgré mes efforts et ma bonne volonté
si tout le monde vivait comme moi il
faudrait bien plus d'une planète
ce constat m'a rendu triste déprimé même
le sentiment d'impuissance m'a envahi la
résignation a gagné sur la colère alors
petit à petit j'ai remonté la pente
mais ce ne sont pas les managers du
bonheur ni lé coach en développement
personnel ni même les barres de céréales
qui monte des noms ce qui m'a aidé c'est
l'amour la légèreté mais aussi la colère
qui est revenu au galop et l'écriture
avec elle car plus on est en colère
plus on éprouve du désir plus on se sent
vivant certes on peut toujours trouver
plus utile qu écrire des livres un sabot
du papier en plus il ya l'engagement de
terrain par exemple mais les deux ne
sont pas incompatibles et un livre a
déjà un pouvoir extraordinaire celui de
donner corps à l'indignation qu'on
l'écrive ou qu'on le lise il permet de
prendre du recul d'approfondir avec plus
de 280 caractère il dure ne s'efface pas
après dix secondes
il se met au service d'une cause et peut
faire bouger les lignes comme on dit
même à petite échelle
oui parce que je ne parle pas de changer
le monde façon start-up d'être un héros
ou de se lancer généreusement dans la
philanthropie avec une fondation une
fois qu'on est devenu un riche
entrepreneur trop facile non non je
parle de continuer à râler à s'indigner
coûte que coûte et d'avoir toujours une
place pour le faire que ce soit le
papier la rue où le divan la colère
devrait être un droit fondamental
aux nombreux sont ceux qui n'en
jouissent pas écrire sur ce qui ne va
pas n'empêche pas par ailleurs de jouir
de la vie ne s'émerveille et on peut
être un gros râleur et un épicurien
notre monde est complexe il va très mal
certes mais il vaut encore la peine
d'être auscultés oui mais quand même dit
on encore entre la critique des start-up
l'écologie profonde et le féminisme
troisième vague c'est un peu le grand
écart non et bien pas tant que ça
prenons quelques exemples vous allez
voir d'après vous qu'est-ce qui a
commencé en premier la domination de la
nature ou la domination de la femme
comment peut-on penser l'une sans
l'autre en fait quand j'entends le terme
d' anthropocène qui désigne l'air
géologique dans laquelle nous sommes
entrés à partir du moment où nos
activités ont eu un impact global
significatif sur l'écosystème terrestre
quand j'entends ce terme d'entrepôts
scène anthropos l'homme
je me demande si on ne devrait pas lui
adjoindre en complément comme ça celui
de patriarche scène l'air du patriarcat
aux conséquences multiples et
insoupçonnées mais dont on sortira
bientôt j'espère d'ailleurs à ce sujet
vous avez remarqué
la colère est trop souvent l'apanage des
hommes pour eux souvent c'est un signe
de puissance de pouvoir d'affirmation de
soi tandis qu'on intime aux femmes
depuis des siècles de rester calme et
discrète sous peine de passer pour des
hystériques ou des petites sentimentale
comme moi en ce moment ça par contre
c'est déjà en train de changer on le
voit bien autre exemple peut-on
envisager un avenir respectueux de la
nature et du vivant sans justice fiscale
sans une économie plus juste et donc un
monde du travail plus respectueux les
technologies gadgets et applications que
la silicon valley développe avec
opiniâtreté vont-ils nous sauver des
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
certains le pensent ceux là même qui
croit avoir inventé des technologies
pour nous rendre éternel
bonne chance
vous voyez ces indignations sont liés
alors si vous ressentez de la colère
face à tout ça ne la fait pas taire ne
l'étouffé pas écouté l'a utilisé là
c'est un moteur qui vous emmènera loin
d'art antilles sans émission de co2
qu'on se comprenne bien pour finir tout
cela ne rend pas la colère plus agréable
à ressentir cela ne rend pas les
absurdités injustice plus facile à
accepter ce même une tâche assez ingrate
en fait mais ça en vaut la peine déjà à
titre individuel vous éviterez ce qu'on
appelle le retour du refoulé en
psychologie
quand on vous refoulé trop une pulsion
et qu'elle revient plus tard par la
fenêtre encore plus fortes comme un
boomerang
ça peut faire très mal ensuite vous
aurez mis vos émotions toutes vos
émotions au service d'une cause qui vous
est cher ne nous voilons pas la face
nous ne sommes pas que des êtres de joie
la vie n'est pas toujours belle comme on
veut nous le faire croire le parfum mais
investir votre colère engagez votre
indignation vous procurera aussi de la
joie et cela vous prouvera qu'il existe
toujours des foyers de résistance et de
création
enfin en écoutant votre colère en vous
indigne ans vous développerez une autre
disposition d'esprit une autre
inclination positive la plus puissante
de tout sans doute qui vous connectera
au monde en devenir
pas celui qu'on voit mourir cette
disposition c'est l'audace merci
[Applaudissements]